And that's why I said it's really common to
have a version string in your manifest file, and you
keep updating that version string. This can be quite
a pain, but it isn't too hard. So once we
have an app cache on the user's machine, on
every subsequent load, the resources will be loaded from the
app cache, even when you're online. If it's an
HTML resource with the manifest For example, that master page
we started with. Then we'll start an async update of
that manifest file at the same time. And then continue loading
the rest of the page. Now, if the manifest has been
changed, the browser will update the files in a new application
cache. But remember, it's already loaded the page. It may
be done loading a page by this point since we do
want to be offline first and we want to make sure that
the page gets loaded as quickly as possible. By the time
the manifest file has been downloaded in the background,
the user is probably already off looking at cat
videos out of the application cache. Now, you can
detect when a new cache has been downloaded and there's
new content available. You can listen for an update
ready event on the window application cache object. The
window application cache represents the application cache system. And
you can get things like the status and progress and
tell it specifically to do things like update
the cache or swap the cache out. So
you have a lot of control over the
application cache. This code here checks for an
update ready event, and if there is actually
an update ready, then it'll actually ask the
user, is it okay to reload this. And if so, it swaps the cache out and reloads.